a guy came over the other night and we
had a con we had a cigar until one
o'clock in the morning
great conversations we had okay great
conversations we had to one o'clock in
the morning and the conversation came
about desantis he was a guy that worked
closely with desantis and he was an
advisor to desantis when desantis was
coming up again people don't realize
this guy's a 43 year old superstar right
now 43 year old superstar right now and
he's fighting but
the the left is trying to figure out any
way possible to cancel this guy and
desantis continues to fight back so
here's what story just came about okay
uh florida tries to lure ships waiting
at backlogged california ports this is a
story i think from last week if you want
to go to page eight
and then desantis is not not just
backing down and he starts recruiting
non-stop but here's what he says
florida is encouraging ships to ditch
backed up ports on the west coast and
head its way while dozens of ships
remain more off the coast of la waiting
to be unloaded in a historic supply
chain scenario ports in florida are
humming
along with little or no delays and are
standing by if ships come ship shipping
companies decide to reroute freighters
to the east coast florida governor
desantis recently invited ships to
reroute and offload their shipments in
florida which has several ports we're
here we have capacity says desantis in
addition to rerouting ships some
recipients of goods that are being
manufactured overseas are also
re-evaluating their ability to ship
using air freight that increased demand
has caused air cargo race to soar
to record levels but the sentence
doesn't stop let me go to the next one
here and then i'll open it up for
dialogue
descent is
planning five thousand dollar bonus for
unvaccinated police to relocate to
florida this is a newsweek story
republican florida governor desantis
said on sunday that he is hoping to sign
legislation that would get unvaccinated
police officers a five thousand dollar
bonus to relocate to a state desantis
commented about police officers in other
states who are losing their jobs because
they are not complying with covet
vaccine mandates on a scientific basis
most of those first responders have had
covet and have recovered so they have
strong protection and so i think that
influences their decision he said
desantis called on police officers
across the country including those in
new york minneapolis and seattle to
relocate to the sunshine state if they
are not being accommodated at their jobs
when you play aggressive so i'm sitting
there and i'm talking to my sister
pauline and she says don't you think
this puts a target on him okay and i
said absolutely i said but what's the
alternative just sitting there and not
doing anything about this you gotta you
get because if you think about who the
last guys that played this aggressive
type of offense was a guy named governor
perry okay and if you guys remember
governor perry where he's like you know
those three organizations you got the
epa and you got i don't know what the
shucks
you wanted to close the three
organizations it couldn't remember
anyways but here's what uh rick perry
did governor of texas he's who recruited
us to texas by the way i'm gonna have to
sit down with him went to the rangers
again with him prior to that orion yeah
prior to abbott so rick perry comes to
california and he goes does a bunch of
talk shows radio shows and he says
if you're if you're a business owner in
the state of california and you're sick
and tired of being taxed and regulated
why don't you come to the great state of
texas we won't tax you we won't regulate
it we'll let you build your business and
do your thing but we want to welcome you
to the state of so he kept aggressively
recruiting people from texas from
california right okay that's a bold move
this guy's making a bold move
here at this point of the game i
guarantee you there are meetings
non-stop
strategy sessions not how to save
america not how to deal with china not
how to deal with the border not how to
deal with the taxes they're having our
strategy sessions how the hell do we get
rid of this guy here that's why biden
doesn't have time to go to the border so
it makes sense but he drove past it in
oh wait you got to give him credit yeah
he drove he did you drove up close
enough so listen desantis
um apparently he's going to be rerunning
it's uh the conversation right now
whether he's going to be running for
office or not has to do with his wife's
health uh it's not you know it's a it's
he has breast cancer yeah it's tough
they're dealing with it but uh you got
to love his audacity to stand up he's
playing off people he is playing
i think i think another big thing for
this as well is you see
how many of us were talking about
desantis just two years ago
he was an accomplishment 18 months
he almost lost andrew gillum the social
media i mean it was a close race man
florida would be in a totally different
position right now had that race not
gone in the favor of rhonda and i think
it just goes to show that during crisis
certain people stand up and certain
people push back time leader yep big
time exactly do you think they're going
to be able to cancel them
i mean it depends on as long as he
doesn't do is unless there's some dirt
on him that that they're going to
somehow pull up i think it's going to be
hard unless you miss
tell me who you can't find dirt on
i mean nobody you tell me who you cannot
find dirt on nobody okay then so do you
think their
research team is working and the
research team for them is who 24 7.
here's their research team folks working
at the irs yep forks working at f yeah
forks working on social media sites
facebook instagram dms text phones this
is their research team it's a pretty
qualified research team by the way that
can get access to any information that
they want do you think they're going to
figure out a way to cancel the santas or
you think he'll make it i think they'll
try but i also think that he's not going
to go down without a fight
i see him as a guy who's going to go
down swinging they're not going to find
something where he's just gonna flat out
lay down and be like all right i'm done
i see him more going down with the ship
if that's the case well he's had a
target on his back for the past two
years since covet started since florida
didn't i mean they locked down for what
two weeks and that was it i mean he's
he's had a target on his back the whole
time and they've yet to cancel him like
like you said they're going to try but
he's he's not going to go down without a
fight david you look like you want to
say something go ahead colombia yeah i
don't think he
can be canceled i think he's in the same
trump situation where i think a lot of
the trump supporters see desantis as the
second coming of trump
and so it's going to be the same
situation where if he runs they're going
to try and find all the dirt any time he
said anything slightly
disagreeable and but he won't go down
it's not even saying something
disagreeable it's about strategy it's
character assassination
it's uh uh manipulation it's
division it's gonna be family women
money taxes comments high school cancel
they're gonna go and find a way to get
something on this guy here's the
question do you think it's there like i
don't think it's there with ron desantis
the way it was with trump trump had to
access hollywood tapes he has all you
know i i could shoot somebody on fifa
it's like a second they'll find
university of florida i believe i'm sure
it was drunk in the 90s did something
stupid women will come out
things happen he's a young guy he's 43
44 what is he 43 september 4th i think
at the end of the day
whether you're on the left or on the
right you got to hand it hand it to the
guy he's doing a great job here in
florida and that's the key right i mean
he's doing a good job a lot of people
would disagree with that that are not in
florida okay but you got to hand it to
the guy and you brought up rick perry i
think he's sharper smarter more
aggressive um
just has better positions i think rick
perry was a a good old texas guy come on
down like i think i think this guy
actually is sharper than rick perry
would you agree he's actually actually
great impersonation thank you thank you
i was just imitating your prayers no
wonder you're rick yours was uh yeah
exactly that was the middle eastern rick
perry
but i think i think um one thing that
we um need to account for is
yes has he been on the
national stage a little bit but he
hasn't been on the national national
front page news
stage yet like trump i think the biggest
person in
desantis's way is not the irs stuff not
social not it's straight up donald j
trump
it kind of reminds me of when
tom brady was um
his rookie year
or even when aaron rodgers came and
brett favre was there you can use a
million different quarterback analogies
santa's is tom brady no meaning like you
have this young talent
you have this young talent who's clearly
talented politically yeah and is doing
good things and is maybe destined for
great things yeah and then you have the
old guard the bread farms of the world
the drew bledsoes of the world the
donald trumps of the world who aren't
just gonna get out of the way and give
the young buck the shot so unless
there's an injury unless there's a trade
unless he doesn't run
i don't think to say like desantis
as much as he might deserve the
republican nomination obviously he has
to earn it
trump's not going anywhere
trump is not going anywhere trump is
going to be the nominee
i've said this a million times i would
vote for desantis in a heartbeat over
joe biden
i don't think the country the country
wants another four years of trump
i don't think
other than the base
we've done the trump thing again let's
get a young like i don't even want
another 70 something year old it's like
getting back with your ex-girlfriend
yeah you know that that's going to be an
abusive relationship it doesn't work yes
david are you dealing with something
right now
yes i just need a second okay who would
you rather have trump or desantis be
your president
uh if that that's that question is easy
question that's not the question though
what's the answer the question is easy
whoever is going to create less
unnecessary enemies and you think that's
the center that's the sentence he's
going to create less unnecessary and i
agree with you unfortunately the
republican base does not i think at the
because they don't think he's going to
get the nomination which is what you're
saying they don't i just think they're
they're all in on trump that's it and by
the way let me just go into the trump
story
because i don't think it's as clear-cut
as you make it i think the republican
party is fighting with whether or not
they can even go through with electing
trump we know what happened we know what
it did to the country culturally yeah it
was americans were better off than they
had been before 59 percent of americans
said they were better off you know at
the end of his uh term than they were
when it started but at the same time
we're well aware of what he did to the
country and the way it collapsed and
what has come because of it so it's i
don't think it's as clear-cut as you
make it that the whole right is behind
donald trump because they're not i think
it's going to be a battle i i wish you
were right i just don't think you are
well do you understand what i'm saying
so let me say this does your position
change depending on who trump's running
mate is if it's a trump desantis ticket
does your position change or it's
regardless is it no trap is it the point
is i don't even know if that is a ticket
we'll cross that bridge when we get
there i don't even know if desantis
wants to
like if you're desantis don't you want
to do it yourself yo i now you're you
have to just kind of get swept in with
trump to know that a a trump tweet
helped him win yeah don't forget that so
a a trump tweet helped desantis win and
it was not it was very close you you
know this you this is your state yeah it
was very clear very close trump tweeted
it out boom done deal by the way yeah
like the the arrows it was very close it
was neck and neck since then rhonda
sanders has now been considered the
potential next president 2024. andrew
gimlin was literally found like a
homosexual gang bang drugged out yeah
doing like not even joking yeah it was
it was bad like he was but he didn't
even invite me bro
was he the one and was he did he joined
in the one in hungary that we covered on
the podcast that time that was a
different one
good memory so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]